croyez le ou non même en juillet cette
boutique de souvenirs de noël du vieux
québec est bondé clients mais cet été si
la catastrophe
le chiffre d'affaires de marquer gaboury
a fondu de 90%
je viens faire brûler un lampion pour
cette demande et que le vaccin arrive
vite c'est comme ça dans les restaurants
sur les terrasses les mesures sanitaires
font mal ou si on peut pas comparer une
saison normale en pourcentage
on est on est en bout de 30 % des gens
vraiment ici normalement le long des
rues j pas de journées l'imprimante
commence 11h30 ce matin jusqu'au soir
mais québec n'est pas complètement
déserté depuis une dizaine de jours les
visiteurs viennent de moins loin mais
ils sont de plus en plus présent arrive
c'est demeuré assez constant à chambly
on vient les vieux et les taux
d'occupation dans les hôtels sont en
fait à la hausse après l'absence quasi
totale des clients pendant le
confinement sur semaine on est à peu
près de 25 30% l'occupation puis la fin
de semaine ça montre la du et des hôtels
à 31 40 à 50 % d'occupation
donc on voit aussi avec les faits avec
le début des vacances de la construction
le moral est bon jacques andré pérusse
eux représentent les commerçants du
vieux québec pour lui le défi c'est de
convaincre les gens d'ici de venir dans
le quartier on entend souvent
commentaire il ya trop de monde ont lieu
au niveau polio pas de stationnement on
trouve la même place pour manger des
terrasses le ya de la place
faites-le c'est sûr qu'on aurait dû
gagner par l'achalandage a presque l'air
normal sauf que les restaurateurs
doivent innover
les tables prennent plus de place dans
les rues et pour l'instant c'est un
succès les gens sentent secure parce que
la distanciation et là qu'on est dehors
donc les agréables on est comme un décor
de cinéma
les gens mangent dans ça se passe
vraiment bien pour l'instant on se
croise les doigts si plusieurs
commerçants disent qu'ils tiendront le
coup l'arrivée de l'automne sans
croisiéristes laisse planer un doute et
un stress considérable en 34 ans
d'existence
non voyez-vous le père noël nous réseau
n'aurait nord-isère toutes sortes de son
pied ici pierre alexandre bolduc radio
canada québec
[Musique]